[Applaudissements]
ma mère elle m'a même chez le dermato
c'est une vraie story elle va mal chez
le dermato et le dermato me regarde et
c'est la première phrase il me dit
écoute et je vous promets que vous
n'aurez plus de boutons à partir de
maintenant je dis mais comment on
pouvait renaître sur une diva ya plus de
place à 9
[Applaudissements]
c'était si tu te rends compte ce qui
s'est passé à l'esc est dynamique savez
article est là avez-vous des couches et
des dd et des [ __ ] hockey fait d'entre
eux via clermont sur le yak romanek
qu'il danse avec deux girafes un job
capucines dans l'émission tout à l'heure
a reconnu mais qu'elle avait vécu une
très belle histoire de trois à quatre
mois
aa avec kev je pense qu'elle est
tellement très belle très belle histoire
d'amour which amené beaucoup de
sentiments et puis malheureusement il ay
la haye après il évacuer vers d'autres
aventures
voilà je trouve ça plutôt bien expliqué
wes a fauché une autre version mac à
côté ils sont énervés un vase il
oui on a dit merci
[Applaudissements]
ah ah